oui à cette crise migratoire il faut
aussi ajouter la crise énergétique qui
menace désormais le vieux continent les
sanctions contre la russie reste de ne
pas être sans conséquence pour les
européens d'où ce plan que la commission
européenne s'apprête à a présenté cet
après-midi les 27 veulent réduire les
importations de gaz en provenance de
russie envisagé aussi la mise en place
de stockage stratégique la
diversification évidemment des
approvisionnements bonjour linlin rifaï
on parle économie avec vous car cette
guerre et les sanctions contre 30 he le
russe continue d'affoler notamment le
cours du gaz et les cours du pétrole
fort saint-louis forte hausse aussi ce
matin pour les cours du gaz et du
pétrole le pétrole par exemple qui est
maintenant au delà des 120 dollars le
baril alors ce qui inquiète en
particulier c'est la possibilité d'un
embargo occidental américain et européen
sur les importations de pétrole et
peut-être même de gaz russe ce qui a eu
un impact dès dimanche d'équidés a
commencé à circuler sur les cours du
pétrole dimanche soir le cours du brent
qui est la référence en europe à frôler
les 140
dollars c'est proche du record absolu
jamais atteint quitté en juillet 2008 au
delà de 147 dollars pareil pour le wti
le pétrole américain coté à new york qui
avait dépassé les 130 dollars dimanche
soir alors même si aujourd'hui on est
plutôt autour des 120 dollars il est
possible que l'on dépasse les records
absolus atteints à l'été 2008 en cas
d'embargo ou de mesures proche donc pour
limiter ou arrêter les importations de
pétrole et de gaz en provenance de
russie il ya des estimations qui ont
déjà été faites par exemple bank of
america qui dit que si un tel embargo
est mise en place est bien le prix du
baril pourrait atteindre les 200 dollars
et du côté russe on va plus loin dans
les estimations le ministre de l'énergie
russe alexandre novak évoque même un
prix au delà de 300 dollars le baril il
évoque aussi l'idée de couper tout
simplement les approvisionnements de gaz
russe vers l'europe vers l'allemagne via
le gazoduc north stream 1 alors dans ce
contexte la très tendu les états unis
ont cherché à temporiser et on via la
porte-parole de la maison blanche que ce
projet cette idée d'embargo étaient
encore à l'étude que rien n'était encore
décidé je vous propose d'écouter donc la
porte parole de la maison blanche
le président américain n'a pas pris de
décision à ce stade au sujet d'une
interdiction d'importation d'une
interdiction d'importer du pétrole de
boost et des discussions sont en cours
en interne et aussi avec nos homologues
et partenaires en europe et dont les
nuls
alors pas encore de décision un côté
américain on l'aura compris côté
européen l'idée d'un embargo sur le
pétrole et le gaz qui suscite pour le
moment des réticences oui pas
d'unanimité au niveau européen surtout
que l'europe l'union européenne est très
dépendant des importations de gaz et
pétrole russe là aussi est le premier
fournisseur de gaz pour l'union
européenne avec près de 5 40% des
importations deuxième fournisseur de
pétrole avec plus de 20% des
importations de brut ce qui a poussé
d'ailleurs le chancelier allemand olaf
scholz à prévenir que les importations
d'énergies fossiles en provenance de
russie sont essentiels pour la vie
quotidienne des citoyens en europe un
point de vue partagé aussi par le
premier ministre néerlandais mark rutte
c'est dans ce contexte là qu'il ya une
réflexion actuellement sur la
diversification des sources d'énergie
des sources d'approvisionnement en gaz
et autres énergies au sein de l'union
européenne par exemple l'allemagne qui
dépend énormément du gaz russe commence
à étudier la possibilité donc d'apporter
davantage de gnl gaz naturel liquéfié
ce qui nécessite des infrastructures qui
sont en train d'être mise en place
l'idée aussi de reporter la sortie du
charbon et du nucléaire est à l'étude il
est aussi à l'étude en italie qui
cherche aussi à diversifier ses
approvisionnements de gaz en provenance
d'autres pays voilà l'italie est l'un
des plus dépendants sur le vieux
continent merci beaucoup line rifaï pour
le décrypter